thanks for the ease of accessibility
almost every new anime nowadays has been
watched by someone somewhere and even if
a great show largely sits under the
radar there will always be a small but
very vocal group they give these shows a
bit of attention after everything is
said and done with Margaret the other
hands there's such a vast pool of titles
that even for those way more involved in
the community its lot easier to pick up
this random hidden gem though you've
never heard anyone talking about so with
this in mind on my new year's
partnership with butch Walker I thought
it'd be fun to test out their selection
and find five random titles I hadn't
read before that I found really fun both
famous manga I'd heard of previously and
some had no idea about going into it
everything here is available in book
walker in eBook form and all that links
are in the description so anything
catches your interest you can use coupon
code you go to get a discount on your
first purchase know this video is not
directly sponsored by them before every
one of you who uses our coupon code does
help me out just to be transparent so
with that our delay let's jump right
into it
it's always very fulfilling and
satisfying to see characters get what
they deserve and man does kakigori do
this to an almost self gratifying point
I've always had a soft spot for underdog
stories that's a god damn degenerate
shown in trash [ __ ] boy than I am but
the feeling is especially sweet when you
couple this with overly Nika testable
characters just waiting to be taken down
a peg
cocky gooey details and og like transfer
students named Jabbar meet you Manko
entering a school focused entirely on
gambling students live and die by
gambling here the features are parenting
a [ __ ] okay with this culminating in
the hierarchy system completely
controlled by the student council the
worth is determined by how much money
you can obtain wealthy fit as a top
enjoying the high life with those in
depth at the bottom becomes the school's
dog later having their life sold be a
marriage child birthing jobs etc you
know well that sounded human slavery
[ __ ] you see all the time in high school
this is where our main read comes in oh
that's right you know shits about to go
down as you probably guessed what makes
kakigori such an addictive read is
watching you make o rise to this system
and that's that Leslie beat you down
powerful foes with seemingly simple
observations if their ability to be able
to see through her opponents and
instantly perceive a situation and use
their own system against them that is
just so satisfying using a mix of
psychological manipulation and cunning
to gain the upper hand it has a very
similar appeal to shows like no game
their life and Kaiji with a character
rising up the ranks by betting them a
series of games but what sets it apart
is our lead girl she's both compelling
and also kind of disturbing initially
I'm innocent naive yo incorporated into
this resisting messed up school so from
please slowly come to realize that
behind her calm demeanor she is as
terrifying or even more so than the
people she takes down it's one of those
theories that it's just such an easy
read and you find yourself to feeling
more and more chaps consistently who
she'll take down neck and how she does
it with the student council members
having a wide mix of chaotic and crazy
personalities just waiting to be taken
off their high horse all this not
mentioning the art which is also pretty
great having said all this there is also
an anime adaptation coming soon in the
summer but even so I think this is
definitely worth a read before that and
once you pick it up you'll find it very
hard to put down what's the matter
there's no need to think so much with
only three cards right do you think I
didn't notice every one article operas
marathon isn't based on what your method
is clumsy you use the same trick two in
both 500,000 yen rounds isn't it natural
that I would suspect something was up
they will be able to fool anyone if
you're not prepared to shed your own
blood because the real fun starts now
I'm sure one point in our lives we've
all felt we were born for something more
than what we are doing now to be
stronger to have more wealth to be more
popular however we rarely get the chance
to feel we've obtained what was needed
to be the perfect place in our lives so
from the creator of Ganz comes in ear
Shiki which shows us what would happen
if two people were to obtain the power
to complete what they perceive is the
perfect life is this a live way to
protect happiness by saving the populace
or by gaining power and instead causing
unhappiness I'll lead eating of shiki's
your average salary man nobody stuck
with a disrespectful family a dead-end
job a disease that makes him look older
than he is and just make things slightly
better he's just been diagnosed with
stomach cancer yep it's just your
typical average depressing reflection on
life until one day he had finally hit by
shining lights that transformed him into
a robot like being who's able to fly
shoe bullets and even heal people yeah I
know okay to stick with me here given
these godlike powers and believing this
is a chance to give justice and goodness
to the world he begins a sudden your
life as Japanese elderly Robocop
becoming his own super-powered vigilante
and writing the injustice he sees in the
world or a
does sound a bit stupid when I say it
out loud
unbeknownst to him though he isn't the
only one who got hit by this life as a
teenager was also given these same
abilities instead of using his tales for
justice though the kid uses it to create
injustice in the world killing anyone
for fun starting by going into people's
homes and massacring their entire family
neither are aware initially of each
other's existence and if the parallel
between both their stories that makes it
work it's a gruesome tale of super
heroes and super villains the darkest
aspect of the human nature and reason
why this manga is so good isn't just
because of the objective stories of Ania
shiki's path of justice and
shuh-shuh-gah meas terrible triad of
injustice but because it isn't nearly as
black and white it's just a battle
between good and evil anyone familiar
would gowns for know that hero Yogi's
not one to shy away from horrific and
disturbing human act in India Shiki is
definitely no exception to this while
our leaders meant to be the symbol of
justice as he encountered more
detestable humans the brand of justice
he serves becomes increasingly harsh
from beating down thugs to mass eye
gouging and it's certainly not something
you see in a family-friendly superhero
movie the kids on the other hand who
initially was portrayed as a sociopathic
serial killer is shown to have a shred
of sympathy in yard moments if you are a
fan of the gans manga this will probably
be right up your alley as aside from the
violence I hope you managed to bring
over his beautiful almost stylized
realism art which really shines is not
only the action scenes but also the
almost grotesque body morphing and hey
there's just something quite cathartic
about seeing a frail elderly looking man
laying the smackdown on a bunch of thugs
and Yakuza this is not one for the faint
of heart but flow to you that can handle
it Ania Shiki is definitely worth a read
let's be honest here most of us know
[ __ ] all about wine if we're ever in a
situation in the restaurant where we
have to pick one
the basic process involves coming
through this menu of fancy gibberish
only to focus entirely on price
having the waiter give you a small
sample where you give it a West Center
twirl even though everyone around you
knows that you look like a pompous
[ __ ] who has no idea what they're
doing and last of all you have that one
sweet tip to discern that yes what you
actually tasted was in fact wine was a
good wine who the [ __ ] knows we all
think the entire thing was a [ __ ]
act people do to look smart you know who
you [ __ ] are but the magic of a manga
like drops of God is that you can make
the entire process not only compelling
but also appreciative of everything that
goes into it she's a kook and Zaki is
the son of one of the most famous wine
critics in the world who also happens to
[ __ ] hate wine being forcefully
taught to hone his sense of taste and
smell from a young age he's loads of
wine his entire life even though he's
never tasted it that is until he learns
about his father's death
bringing the difficult get his father
isn't death his will say that he will
only give away his million dollars worth
of wine awaited the person I can
correctly name what he has identified as
the 13 best wines in the world was the
very best being known as the jaws of
gods just to spice things up Shizuka
needs to compete with his newly adopted
wine genius brother-in-law over who can
do this first and is thus thrust into a
world of wine where yes uses natural
skill beaten into him as a kid to
overcome this pretentious [ __ ] trying to
steal his family legacy through the
journey I lead take getting over his
hatred of wine and learning to forgive
and wanting to be closer to his now
deceased father you are not learning way
more about wine you initially couldn't
imagine in a way that's incredibly
entertaining finding out a variety of
tastes of wine can give how achieved one
can surpass even the most expensive if
you know what you're looking for and how
truly hard it is to become a
professional in the world of wine
it gave me an understanding that it's
not just about wealthy snooty people
trying to show off their wealthy snooty
knowledge but it's about drink that
invokes feelings that non-ells can we
just take the time to taste and truly
appreciate it the way they describe the
feeling choosing the right wine sounds
really magical like listening to the
perfect song or appreciating a beautiful
painting we end up learning all this
through shifu's eyes and a real beauties
that we see is growth as a character as
he not only learned more about wine but
also about himself with the wines that
really connect and say something to him
of course all this builds up to the most
exciting showdowns and my favorite
moments were the times when the
characters were competing to choose the
right wine where all the knowledge is a
manga throws at us comes in
use in most satisfying ways this mix of
competition character growth and actual
knowledge and appreciation behind wine
is what make Joseph God a real surprise
for me has I never thought the manga
about one could gripped me as much as it
did and maybe you'll come out of it like
me thinking wow I guess why to do more
than just give me a banging headache in
the morning yeah what's wrong told me
May
I thought you were 99% sure about that
wine jack 1999 George a Romney roshambo
newsela Samaras is your answer isn't it
what was your choice tell me what wine
you cracked this is what I chose as one
of the twelve the first apostle how how
come the speech I'm 100% sir we live in
a time when social media plays an
integral part of modern society as
terrifying or optimistic as it sounds
our world we're all competing for the
retweet or share buttons lives of
broadcasters with an enriched filter on
them and snarky appears about anime and
Mora aired out in public for all to see
it's essentially one massive game that
we are all playing where you are your
own avatars with all sorts of other
players out there so what happens if we
take all these elements and put it into
a game with actual stakes behind it well
then you get real counts ruin account is
a new social media trend to sweep the
nation in a hypothetical world where
Facebook's became uncool when grandmas
started using it YouTube became a family
for any exclusive safe space Twitter was
a toxic cesspool of public opinion and
everyone else got bored of seeing people
putting Instagram filters on their lives
oh wait this is all turned on its head
however when thousands of users are
suddenly sucked into the world of real
account where users have to complete a
series of games to escape the toy states
however if you lose all your followers
then you die but if you fail the game
you also die and so does everyone that
follows you oh ho that's right you guys
are far the premises you span a desk
game tournament we've seen a lot in
anime but the real thing that makes it
interesting is how it touches on
subjects well very relevant today and
puts the creative spin that puts things
into an entirely different perspective
the exaggerated view of the importance
of followers on our social media gives
us a false sense of self-worth but how
much does that really matter in the
grand scheme of things really consoles
we just touch on that subject but also
creates a great spiracles view how are
you approach our online persona each
death game is themed around a different
part of our collective
online behavior whether it be about
those who seek attention or how we judge
people in a surface level and makes you
think about behavior which never already
passes your mind that people do on a
daily basis online how close are we
actually to someone just because we're
friends with them on Facebook how much
do you really know about a person when
their lives are put through a glorified
filter do you change your behavior just
because you gained some anonymity
through the web or how about a game
where your life literally hangs in the
balance of making a post I can gain a
certain light to this like ratio it's a
fascinating read because we've all
played or seen people play these games
before so of course we never really
thought about them as games we're just
the way that people acted for the
instant gratification of receiving a
like or favorite and how cheap that
actually is which is why for this video
we should aim for 20,000 likes on this
video like comment subscribe
we'll say right now that I did not enjoy
the last arc of the manga nearly as much
as the rest of it but it was definitely
a fun ride over and an easy
recommendation for anyone who's been a
part of the social media game which I
assume you already are watching this on
a video sharing platform it's a very
interesting commentary for this thing
that you've played an active part in
presented in a simple death tournament
format that's fun easy to follow and
everyone is familiar with so if that
sounds interesting to you then it's
definitely worth reading through a bit
of this it's remarkably hard to find
some form of media that you know will
become a classic that was made within
your lifetime and even hard it's fun one
that can be well-liked by just about
everyone who decides to view it Vinland
saga is one of those very things now I
know this is not exactly a new
recommendation by any means for those of
you familiar with manga but for many of
you who have never delved into this
world I can wholeheartedly say that this
is one of the greatest manga of all time
to never get an anime adaptation
it's a bloody tale of revenge and a
historic epic reminiscent of titles like
berserk and vagabond
the setting is 1013 England in the
brutal time of the Vikings the rafin is
a skilled young Viking who witnessed the
death of his father by the hand of a
scarlet the leader of a mercenary group
as just a young boy driven by pure
hatred and a desire for revenge he joins
the very mercenary group who murdered
his father in hopes of one day defeating
and killing a scholar in a one-on-one
duel though while that is just the basic
premise there is absolutely no way I can
cover the amounts of layers contain here
in just the shore eka mendacious softens
path of revenge is a saga sprawling with
violence Redemption and the me
meaning of being a warrior one thing
that really stands out early on is so
dynamic the first friend shares with our
antagonist asked aloud maybe the venom
who killed Saracens father to trigger
these events but he's also the closest
thing to Sorensen's mentor who raised
him to be the skilled warrior he ends up
being able to manipulate all the anger
and hatred to keep him under control
binding him to this web of tension and
violence these are just two characters
in a very rich and diverse cast and the
series is filled with deep and complex
relationships such as this that really
grips you and builds on this epic tale
that will keep you on the edge of your
seat
if there is one reason this manga might
not be for you if that it's
unforgivingly brutal not only in
presentation but also in theme and tone
morality is not something that is black
and white and a major theme is the
ambiguous line between what is right and
wrong casting a shadow over every action
our characters take in a malevolent
world drenched in blood nothing here is
romanticized and the atrocities that
occur feel soaked in an air of realism
you witness the viciousness of war and
the toils it has not only on our Viking
main characters but also on innocent
people who just wish to survive but as
this brutality that adds a real depth to
the story and character it's not the
kind of violence that feels gratuitous
or edgy it's heavy ruthless like the
story itself and often times you can
finish a chapter feeling exhausted and
drained of course I cannot mention this
manga without talking about the
spectacular art it's extremely brutal
and gory but it's true and very
realistically and it has incredible
attention to detail some of the panels
are absolutely breathtaking detailing
landscapes with the devastation of
battles fought or sometimes it's a
village or field whatever the case is
definitely some of the best parts of the
world of manga has to offer this title
is an absolutely classic in the manga
world and for good reason it's rarely
get see a manga so well crafted in every
aspect and there's no way I can do the
series justice without a full video on
it so if you haven't done so already you
owe it to yourself to read this
masterpiece because it'll be a decision
that you will not regret and that's
everything I wanted to mention in this
one video if anything sounds like
something you'd want to check out they
are all available on book walking in the
links in the description use coupon code
get out for a discount on your first
purchase even if you're just buying the
first volume to check things out it'll
help me out for every one of you who
does and also the industry too as
everything here is 100% legal and now
that me and Alan have votes in the last
week and a half editing this video and
are both on the
insanity I think it's time for a little
treat oh [ __ ] do you see that last
roller ha ha god I forgot what he looked
like
[Music]
hey guys hope you enjoyed that video
thank you very much this month two
Thrones melts Jared Cattell gay brown
Vincent Moony Vulcan and everyone else
impatient for helping to spawn me for
this month so this video is that she
basically done last week to photo it's
gonna be a quick and easy video but who
knew that making a manga video would say
to people editing this all day every day
until their sanity is always gone to get
as well week late yeah they took way
longer than we anticipated so if you do
end up using the coupons the book Walker
we do we definitely appreciate it
but at the end of the day we hope you
enjoyed how the final video looked I'll
also be has MCM London next week so
anyone there be on the lookout I'll
probably be setting up a meet-up of a
channel some day so I'll be able to look
out for that as well anyway that's it
for me
I've been gig out and I'll see you all
next time